fantastic to have you here today is over
the premiere of infinitely polar bear
now of course this is a movie that's got
two superheroes in but it's acting very
real life characters who had it compare
making this to say God is the galaxy or
avatar um oh god I am just such a I hate
to say it but I am sort of like a
happy-go-lucky person with every project
that I do and I and I go into it
wholeheartedly and completely open and
the only times that I get a little extra
nervous is when I have to play real-life
characters and this is sort of the
second time that I've had to do that
because there is a bigger responsibility
that you have to to maintain the
integrity of a path that was walked
before you so there there there are some
limitations to what you can add into
your character and what you have to try
to to portray as close as possible to
what really happened but this one once
we got through the first day of shooting
was absolutely beautiful because my I
was there so she was able to always be
this fountain of information and kind of
like this compass to always keep us in
the right path and then her mom Peggy
was able to spend a great deal of time
with us while we were shooting so
whenever I needed some comfort or
information I can just go and and lean
on her and go so Peggy tell me about
this moment what really happened and and
it was just it was great for mark and I
because we always felt that we had
amazing and direct references so we
never felt like lost or disrespectful or
anything with the movies peaceful night
you